welcome to this blitz game this is a
game against me cold car 1985 I have to
check that is that who is that the kid
out my you're off okay so let's go see
form okay a Queens gambit accepted yeah
that's not one of my strong suits
running I never studied a line in much
detail there it says it's just so rare
you never really um Peter this yeah very
virgin to study something and in my case
I never got around to to doing it so
what do you go here Queenie to is the
word line on main line where the bishop
moves as a four and the capture a very
often captured okay let's do that some
it's very safe of course check yeah
that's an interesting question if black
should down cheek on d1 or allow the
capture on the eight many people
actually play it like my your office
doing here because they feel that it
does make sense to have the king only
seven anyway um yeah maybe over here
that was one idea of the early Bishop to
e2 aha interesting so is he really
intending to give me the bishop pair
there you know I guess is hard but let's
continue the same with Bishop b2 first
so go for Knight e5 I don't know this
seems this seems fine
if I go a for he might take on see form
Bishop c4 95 that looks a bit awkward
yes a probably just look T one out for
96 maybe okay then let's cover that that
Bishop probably make sense anyway so
again a form I'm not sure about if that
makes lots of sense so let's use all the
pieces and have some look at that Bishop
1c5 and I'm not threatening something I
believe but ok now he's taking night
before something it's just a 3 has
nothing going on there for CSM basically
egg equalised here as I said the Queens
gambit accepted I never really looked at
something in detail and I got stuck with
that Queen tradeline okay I'm not taking
I mean it's really just absolutely
nothing ok so I'm going here anyway OIC
able to take on h2 where it would be
crazy a little bit but 92 should age 29
I don't believe it am I going to wear
I'm going to gamble on that if that
works all the power to him taking on h2
you can play Bishop b5 though that's a
quite decent move
know that that was was interesting okay
um night there where is he going here
don't quite understand ok I'm going to
force that trade here or is he going
back you might be going back to c6 but I
have 90 for coming so i don't know i
think you should probably take it there
might be a moment where i have to think
about bishop age tool but currently g3
Knight f3 will be be safe an interesting
moment I can try to maybe play Bishop c6
but i will have 94 94 which looks Ted
awkward ok so do we have good connection
here I have to check out yesterday had
awful connection now it seems fine hmm
so what is the big point here why is he
thinking for so long
hmm and I'm missing something entirely
here on that's something no thinking
maybe I missed something that I don't
know I should have seen night you force
what I'm thinking about all night c4 as
I said those two moves nights you for he
definitely has to he cannot take he
cannot take 94 bishop yeah well let's do
that yeah he had to go there yeah the
ship f3 maybe okay Bishop Bishop c6 will
definitely be okay i am again but the
position is equal i mean it's not i
really don't have anything his long thin
think at least down let me catch up on
time
so what now is B 5 the movement might be
yeah might be a move okay let's let's go
here turn again p 5 p 593 you should be
quite okay route du monde yeah it is
just equal what can you do it's a bit
boring yeah I know after we look at
something against the Queens gambit
accepted one time but it's a tree they
never play it in in tournament shares
this is why I often recommend that
opening for black it's it's one of those
openings that it's really if totally
okay but it's kind of underestimated so
now I have this here right I don't get
it quite what does he have some weird
combination I wish of h2 coming or no
before 9i morning idea for maybe as well
but okay before should be alright so to
hear ya when the poll on h2 but I don't
think you can take it so may five is not
so great that I have to play that but I
don't think it's a it's a huge deal
really
the time mr. the only serious issue
issue him now okay that's a bit
uncomfortable hmm I understand maybe we
can get the king over to be five that
that would be really awkward we can take
and go F for that that's at least some
kind of tribe check yeah
check
can you see five that's a bit
uncomfortable oops now that set was a
mostly brother didn't didn't really do
much harm but it was still a Muslim
check black forfeits on time yeah okay
that was not the most deserved victory
ever but what can you do it was
basically equal the OL of the whole game
he had a little bit of something after
he had um he after he was able to UM to
force my pawns to 22 dark squares and
that was a bit bit awkward maybe I
should have gone Knight d4 here that
would have been easier yeah i was a
little bit concerned that he may be has
this move but it's not a big deal i have
king be three yeah this this is what
varied me but I have this check okay
that's not really on well I can go here
actually that that's really okay as
always this going for me and if he takes
it this is going to be totally fine yeah
and before this is now a little bit
worrying I mean I shouldn't lose but
it's a little bit varying and with the
newer time maybe that f3e form can I
don't know I still think it's so it
should be a draw check
it is quite check simplify this position
and okay the outside maybe this is not
really great yet with the outside passer
that is getting them okay i had as i
said i didn't have much time but I
wasn't really aware of that he was also
that much down on time here g g3 was
strong here g3 intending this in this
before that's the the engine and then
slide check check yeah like winter it's
the it's a right the right Bishop here
yeah of course he he basically am here
he blundered into this was a mouse slip
he landed into that I think I'm here
we're talking about said to draw and I'm
not totally sure let's say sick in here
I can take here takes a five I don't get
the Jeep own right I don't get it back
you can block here yeah black it's
probably winning here yeah yeah I really
have to do something about the Queens
gambit accepted let's see maybe next
time I can present some other line it's
really a TED boring this thing okay well
thanks for watching